okay let's go to the capital of Turkey
Ankara now where Cinema joins us live
from a crisis center
we've been hearing how the government
has been accused of a slow rescue
response in many of these hard areas
what are they saying to you what is the
latest when it comes to getting Aid out
there
they say it was difficult to reach out
to these areas at first because
because the airports were closed and
because the climate the weather
conditions didn't allow it to happen and
as having spoken to the officials in the
Turkish disaster management agency they
also acknowledged that it was difficult
for them to reach out to some places at
the very beginning for instance hatai
turkey's Border City with Syria is one
of them and the damage in the city the
catastrophe especially in the city
center antakia is a huge on the very
first day of the earthquake we had no
information about hatai for instance
because the runways of the airport was
damaged there were three other airports
like this but as of yesterday as the
vice president announced hatai airport
resumed flights and the first flight
from National Airline carry Turkish
Airlines landed in
which will contribute on bringing the
aid to the people in need in those areas
but of course we have spoken to some
military sources as well as the area
right now those 10 cities are under
state of emergency and Military is
involved they are providing help to the
search and rescue teams and they are
helping out for a public order and they
told us that on the very first day since
most of those cities that was that were
affected by the earthquake were going
through heavy weather conditions it was
very difficult for them for their
helicopters and planes to take off as
well that's why they had to use drones
which were unmanned and it had no risk
so everything came together but of
course there's still many say the
experts have been were warning that
there would be an earthquake in that
area maybe it was bigger than uh
expected in terms of uh the affected
area the scale but they they still
accuse the government for being
unprepared for that okay there for us in
Ankara uh good to speak to you uh just
let's return back to those pictures that
we were looking at on our screens their
uh that live uh picture of that box yeah
there we are uh if you're just joining
us those are from kalaman marash where a
rescue crews are currently working to
free a mother and her newborn child it's
a very delicate work by the rescue
workers
apparently they are still alive under
that Rubble they've been there for seven
days so let's go to Stephanie Decker who
is somewhere close to the scene in
kalaman marash what are you hearing
about that rescue operation of that
mother and her newborn child
at the scene basically it's been going
on since last night there is obviously
Turkish workers here volunteers a
Spanish Rescue Team I just spoke to them
basically they identified with thermal
imagery at least two people alive they
said they weren't going to speculate on
who exactly they were there are rumors
that it is a mother and a newborn
potentially also a grandmother rumors
that the grandmother may not be alive
what they're doing now and we can
probably vanity just shows you a little
bit of the scene and this is some good
news that everybody needs here if this
is going to be something that we end up
seeing people being brought alive seven
days later so there you can probably see
the Spanish rescue teams you have
obviously the local Turkish workers the
militaries come in here as well because
of now the news that this pretty much
confirmed that you have at least two
people alive under the rubble what
they're doing is they're digging a hole
through what still seemed to be quite
intact shops here they we believe uh
them to be two or three buildings down
in the rubble from what we're being
under being told so a tunnel is being
dug this way another tunnel is being
done from the side
um and again it's meticulous work
because it's so sensitive when you are
trying to get to survivors we were just
talking to a Turkish volunteer at
another site he says he's volunteered in
many other earthquakes he went to
Indonesia he said I have never seen I
have never seen the amount of
Destruction that we have here he says
the way we work when we identify as
Survivor is then they call in uh the
teams with specialized equipment and he
says but it is so slow because we have
to take utmost care not to you know
cause any damage to the buildings that
already structurally damaged to perhaps
cause any injury or death on the
survivors so this is why it's taking so
much time I can tell you there's a lot
of media here
um it's been seven days of reporting
majority I would say of death and
destruction and heartbreak so this kind
of news when people here on the seventh
day a week on that there may be
survivors uh is something that everyone
certainly is hoping for but again a
meticulous task and it is going to take
time okay thank you for that uh
Stephanie Deco there for us in
calamarash where we believe rescue crews
are trying to free a mother and her
newborn child let's go to our
correspondence
who is live for us on the Turkish Syrian
border where AID has been making its way
into Syria so talk us through the
situation where you are particularly in
Northwest Syria where there's been so
much criticism about Aid reaching that
part of the country
definitely here there is a huge
criticism toward the International
Community civilian seeing that the
International Community has helped so
little so far but the only thing that
International Community is telling them
is that we are with you but however they
say that we need much more than words so
we are in front of gilvego the border
crossing right against that there is a
Babel Hawa the Syrian side and a little
ago there has been six trucks from the
United Nations Aid convoys and they just
passed the border and this A's are going
to be delivered to the people in
Northwest and a little bit later there
will be another eight Convoy coming from
Qatar so qataris have the liver the aid
another this is the first aid Convoy
yesterday and also with the military so
with the uh the medical equipments and
the Medical Teams as well and now the
second one is just about to arrive here
so you can't he see right behind me the
situation is quite dramatic so so the
funeral service car is there and it just
got the bodies of the syrians those who
were living in turkey and that that died
under the rubbles now their bodies are
being taken by these funeral services
cars and then loaded on the other track
and a little bit later they are going to
take them to Syria to bury them in to
bury them in their uh in their home
country and also there are families as
well these weary families are just
coming flowing in and out and many of
them are here just to pass the border
and hopefully to meet their loved ones
alive so this is the situation that is
going on here so in Northwest Syria
there are roughly around four to five
million people and the the aid is
desperately needed here because it has
been more than a decade that the Civil
War simply has Savaged Northwest Syria
people were homeless and you know they
have just made the the makeshift homes
tans and also the shelters now the
disaster here is just overlapping a
decade-long Civil War and now the
earthquake so the situation is quite
dire as of now more than 5 000 people
have already died but they have been
killed by the earthquake that hit the
the region and there are thousands of
people or the thousands of people now
are really living through the hot
conditions particularly during the night
there's no tant no proper food no
electricity no water they have we have
nothing so that's why the a that is
going through Syria is too little they
say they say it is too late and too tiny
so thousands of homes also here have
been either collapsed or they are
heavily damaged and the the health
facilities here are struggling because
they're also severely damaged they're
overwhelmed by the passions those who
are going through traumas or those who
are still injured and they receiving
very very little on the other hand
rescue a force here are also extremely
difficult so we're coming from the
Turkish side definitely the devastation
the scale of Devastation is unimaginable
however we can see that the the the
rescue Force are relentlessly continuing
and the the sounds of the machines that
are constantly working around the clock
but in Syria that is not the case they
they lack the the modern equipment the
modern risky equipments they lack they
do not have the heavy lifting
machineries they do not have the diggers
they do not have the escalators they
even do not have the light to work
through the night so this is not a
situation that people can work during
the day and have rest during the night
the work the rescue Air Force needs to
continue 24 hours a day so that's why
there are lots of Greece there is lots
of Grief Lots of complaints loss of
feeling of Abandonment they say that the
International Community simply has
abandoned us and we are for getting
it really is so Bleak isn't it Russell
said uh speaking to us there live from
the Turkish Syrian border
well as we were hearing there from
Russell anger has been building in Syria
with survivors saying that the
International Community has let them
down Abdel monem qasem al-razouk is one
of those angered by the response
I'm here to watch and remember
the memories here I see my sister's
dress her son's clothes and all of them
their smell is here when they remove
everything I won't come back
here's their car
the water tank
the solar panels memories
the whole world led the Syrian people
down
this destruction was in Europe or any
other foreign country the whole world
would have gathered here to rescue those
killed
but here no one cares where this place
no one asked about us and we were bombed
Barrel bombs were dropped no one cared
about us
we're getting nothing from turkey and
not from the government side we're here
besieged